America it is really good if you're
really really rich and forms just
released their list of the 400
billionaires uh these people are worth a
combined 2.3 trillion dollars they're
doing pretty good we're not gonna read
all four hundred of them for you what is
going to look at the top ten i think you
know most of these names bill gates at
the top he is worth 80 1.2 billion
dollars warren buffett number to the
koch brothers they're four and five the
koch brothers by the way they their
hands in manufacturing trading in
investments i know it is talking about
them all times i want to clarify that
and then uh the waltons that seven eight
and nine those are the walmart people uh
so three people that own three family
members look Jesus they're multiplying
like gremlins yeah combined they would
be on top with Bill Gates oh yeah their
whole do anything there people keep
saying at walmart struggling right now
but I'm pretty sure they're they're
doing okay and then of course mark
zuckerberg was at number 10 um so let's
start with the walmart thing because i
thought that was injuring i miss the
woman and a family there and they're
still all over that list do you remember
that story a while back where Walmart
was doing a food drive on thanksgiving
fourth it was all I wanted my knees
right there so we covered that literally
they were doing a food drive for their
oh yeah like put canned goods here so
that I can make a Thanksgiving dinner i
work at Walmart yeah I can't afford to
make Thanksgiving dinner but you know
they're the richest people in the
country combined okay so what do we do
about that because I do believe in
capitalism I don't know of a better
economic system that's working and yet
you see this and then you see those
numbers which are completely insane and
the amount of money that this family has
wrangled out of the economy and then you
hear stories like this where they barely
are paying their employees and all the
bad workers practices and they're not
allowed to unionize and all this stuff
and I think they're the biggest employee
employer in the United States and I make
Lana I'm not or but sounds believable
okay um how do we negotiate those two
things like that they can have this much
money and also have their people
readings I don't think we can and I
think that's the issue we can't
negotiate at all we don't have the power
to do so we especially don't have the
power to do so today compared to you
know decades ago or hundreds of years
ago because of legislation that's put in
place that essentially says money speaks
Citizens United poor Supreme Court
ruling ever Yeah Yeah right so so we
have policies that maintain people in
power and keep others you know poor and
unable to afford a turkey on
Thanksgiving Day it's pretty gross I'd
yeah I recently watched and I'm just
gonna kind of defer to Robert rush on
this because he is an economist and he's
really smart and he knows was an idea
but i recently watched the documentary
based on his book called inequality for
all which is incredible check it out
it's on netflix right now and he makes a
really good point which is that people
who don't understand economics often try
to say that the free market decides the
frick capitalism is free the market
decide there's no such thing as a free
free market in any capitalist nation
there's some combination of capitalism
and socialism and the market is only as
free as the government decides to to
regulate it there are always going to be
regulations on a free market for example
we don't trade with Cuba which we should
that's a different issue but yeah
tariffs for example look at illegal
kinds of trades we block the black
market for example there are a lot of
regulations that we put in place but for
some reason people like to pick and
choose which ones I think of as being
moral or immoral regulations the way
that we solve this is that we have
legislation in place that protects the
middle class and we have since the
nineteen seven straight in
administration really we have slowly but
surely been stripping away protections
from the middle class and propping up
the richest of the rich by giving them
insane tax breaks where these people I
would not be surprised if the effective
tax rate that these folks were paying
was close to ten percent when I pay
thirty-six percent taxes right okay so
you got me my next like five questions
fell in there okay so how so first off
how do we tax these people then because
they're because they're gajillion
loopholes they own the politicians
citizens united they own the very
politicians that are supposed to
regulate them this is not this is not
truly free market of course because
they're in charge of the people and the
regulators and all that and we find all
the time that the second politicians are
done where do they get their next job
Eric Cantor well he was never on Wall
Street before but got kicked out of
Congress and now he's making three and a
half million dollars a year on Wall
Street so how do we possibly figure out
a way to tax these people it's
incredibly difficult because when you
figure out a way to tax these people
they figure out a way to skirt the law
and to find a loophole around the
attacks I do have to say there have been
a couple of changes more recently and
the Obama administration has tried to
crack down a little bit on tax evasion
so we've seen some changes in tax
inversions and cap and the capital gains
tax has increased also in the last few
years so things like that can help but
example gay sex which is just money that
your money is made a little bit higher
and again I'm not for grudging these
people money or successor ability to
earn it's what things like that like yes
it is a little something like I do want
to Obama's incredibly years here's an
amazing point that was made again in
this documentary there was a really rich
guy who was like I'm [ __ ] filthy rich
i own this crazy company i'm a venture
capitalist i'm crazy rich I make
billions of dollars a year and he made
this point which had never really
settled with me before which is eighty
percent of the functioning American
economy is based on purchases of goods
and services and the way to make that
boom is through the middle class and he
said this I Drive the nicest Audi you
can buy it's a really expensive Audi but
it's still just one car I can only drive
one car I'm one person i only buy two
pillows i make a thousand times more
than my employees but i don't buy a
thousand times more pillows I don't
contribute to the economy as much as the
middle class i [ __ ] my money the same
way that all the rich people do
trickle-down economics is a [ __ ] mess
it just doesn't add up right so for the
people that believe in trickle-down
economics their belief somehow is that
if you have these really rich people
well then they'll wanna boats and you
have someone to make a boat and then
they'll want
what it's another fancy thing that rich
people have a helicopter and fancy phone
keep this all right but that basically
it doesn't work just because of the
numbers he just can't it just doesn't
work and you know what you'll see in
your comment section right now is that
you'll see a lot of conservative people
saying things like you just don't
understand economics which is a very
common kind of backlash immediate
argument but the truth is the people who
do understand economics to do understand
it way better than I do are saying the
same thing and when it comes down to how
do we close the tax loopholes how do we
we can't do any of that until we get
money out of politics that all of these
arguments come back down when you strip
away the [ __ ] to the fact that our
politicians are paid for by corporations
that if I have ten dollars versus your
five dollars you're my politician is
going to vote my way not yours it's as
simple as that it's a pretty disgusting
equation and now apparently corporations
are people and we let unlimited money
into the system we do the exact reverse
of what sort of rationality would
dictate but that's what's going on